welcome to this video playing under us
from Austria is something that just
looks like no okay we got this laughs
and I often play Queen b3 let's see what
he's got against that Bishop g4 on the
ship f5 we shouldn't have five yeah here
white has two principal ways to play
Knight c3 rook e1 or or three yeah I
like this e39 it's um somewhat more
conservative way to play very
interesting tries to occupy the center
with the night the somewhat peculiar
thing about him move like knighted force
in this situation I don't have a knight
on on c3 so he's got nothing he cannot
exchange the night for for a piece so
I'm I can maybe just plain i t1 and the
ticket he might place if to seek any
place he five or five maybe but my
development is not not especially ideal
and maybe I should just exchange the
night
okay come on keep it keep it simple
night you won that f3 was the the
principled alternative yeah I think he
probably would exchange now not
exchanging it's a bit strange my pieces
are a bit clocked up but still okay you
know my idea is to just play for next
efore and tonight see for maybe yes this
was of course of course possible you for
still probably and then taking take here
or Eastern night see 494 is a move he
takes default Bishop f4 now this is
quite nice them so let's do that
maybe de 595 Bishop f4 as Sam is also an
eidm taking Bishop f4 just just should
be comfortable for wide I was surprised
that he decided to go to g6 I was
thinking more of the ship e6 but maybe
then I can can take okay so he went he
went with f6
interesting
how to play here listen this Bishop is
probably going to have seven thinking
about our weight I can also play d5 d5
is also also move takes pawn takes hmm
difficult difficult okay I do that
difficult to evaluate there was also
Knight e3 interesting yeah
and hard to say oh this is I didn't
expect which does not mean it is bad or
anything just unexpected
okay d6 is probably nonsense okay I need
to exchange this piece almost in any
case
Bishop 25 is too too annoying to keep on
the board okay opposing the Queen after
move like cd5 this C file could become a
big problem okay interesting is there
some intermediate move probably not
taking with both is interesting actually
and also taking with the night as this
cell has Knight f5 at some point
see five I'm doing for reform
Bishop age three is an is an important
resource here
these six probably not
I rather activate this Bishop
[Music]
no t6 t6 is a threat I think maybe not
maybe not actually he still has going to
be made still ask windy area that's
probably not a serious threat but maybe
d6 Queen B 8 Queen G FOIA does this
threatens yeah this is a threat Quincy
form this is not a big difference he
still has to go to be aid
not otherwise 97's just winning winning
outright black resigns yeah in this case
half to cream VN I can also I can just
take c5 but I wanted to go queen g4 does
this kill is black he cannot go here
Jack Jack's wide wins easily and Bishop
g6 I have I have simply this check check
and now something and over basically
this this is gone this is gone the tubes
is too much too many weaknesses yeah it
was a situation here around him where
black is always under pressure Bishop c5
yeah I think this is all looks looks
fairly normal you might be able to
improve but here you probably maybe you
should take on d5 at some point not not
sure about this the position is better
for white in any case something like
this this simply more activity for for
watch em and it's difficult difficult to
defend a computer here is already on
more than one point +4 wild you know
after c5 I have I have this at the end
before in connection with Bishop h3
something like this where the idea could
be to simply take here and take c5 and
black structures collapsing this yeah
the comp now wants to take haha yeah
computer wants to take and play 95 this
is a very clean solution of course
strongest he cannot really take too much
and after a queen move white can snap
this as there is this fork
okay so Bishop age three to eight you
know I'm always keeping some edge and
only six wins yeah I think looked like a
decent game nothing
nothing a big to improve upon okay
thanks for watching